you've been in so many great films it's
hard you know I list like five of them
and you realize no there's probably you
know 45 that I could list what's the one
you hear about when you walk around this
street what are the one when people see
you they go hey you you you think you
know it's a fun game when someone's
approaching with a smile on their face
they could be like oh my god I love
fight clothes there's some that are that
are sort of a wide array of people like
and then some people you can kind of see
him coming but I bet he likes the
Italian job with a score or something
like that and then but I I was in you I
was at home in New York and this guy
came up the other day big big you know
mustache a Mets shirt big gut big like
construction worker hands and I'm just
I'm kind of waiting for it and he goes
he goes I love you in Wes Anderson's
moonrise kingdom you and all the other
twelve-year-old girls thank you thank
you
you're the most sensitive guy on the
crew that's it Ryan telling you I I've
said this before but I've I was walking
through New York once and it was like
early in the morning when there the
trash men are coming through and they're
they're emptying the trash can and this
this guy like leans out of a trash truck
and he's just like this total die who
could have had a cigar coming out of the
side of his mouth he didn't he was like
I enjoy you I just love the word enjoy I
enjoy you like don't look like you enjoy
anything but I don't want to know
exactly what that means